هذه الجزيرة الصغيرة الواقعة على الجانب الغربي من
شبه جزيرة أنتاركتيكا هي موطن
لوسائل راحة غير متوقعة ،
سأقوم بإرسال
مدير مكتب البريد الخاص بي ، هذا صحيح ، فهذه هي
الحقائب الكبيرة للبريد وهذا
مكتب بريد شديد البرودة ونائية جدًا ،
إنه جزء من التراث  بجانب بورتلوك
هاربور ، أول قاعدة دائمة في أنتاركتيكا في المملكة المتحدة
والتي كانت ملجأ
للعلماء المستكشفين والسياح
لأكثر من 75 عامًا ، كما تضم ​​أيضًا
متحفًا حيًا ومتجر هدايا
كل عام ، يتم اختيار فريق صغير
لتشغيل الموقع وصيانته من نوفمبر
إلى نوفمبر.  مارس أو الصيف في
النصف الجنوبي من الكرة الأرضية ، يعيشون في أماكن قريبة
في كوخ خشبي بدون اتصال بالإنترنت
ولا توجد مياه جارية
[موسيقى]
أوه ، وهل ذكرنا البطاريق ، دعنا
نقول فقط إنهم يستطيعون الحصول على القليل من
التدريب اللاذع للفريق يبدأ أكثر من 8
على بعد 000 ميل خلال فصل الصيف البريطاني ،
ولكن من يريد حقًا وظيفة مثل
هذه ،
أعتقد أن العنوان كان كما لو كنت أريد أن أذهب
إلى Phantom Hearts ، اذهب وعد البطاريق
وكنت مثل تمامًا لقد
عملت في البيع بالتجزئة لمدة 15 عامًا زائد  وبعد ذلك
عندما ألقيت نظرة على
الوصف الوظيفي لمدير المتجر ، كنت
مثل ، في الواقع ، أنا مؤهل تمامًا
لهذا الدور الذي
تعيش فيه تعمل جنبًا إلى جنب
طوال الوقت وليس هناك مكان
أذهب إليه ، لذلك هذا ما حدث في نهاية هذا الأسبوع  كل شيء يتعلق
بغرفة الأخطاء التي يعيشونها جميعًا لقضاء
عطلة نهاية الأسبوع فوق بعضهم
البعض وما زال يحاول نوعًا ما محاكاة
ذلك قليلاً ، لذا فقد قضيت الكثير من
مماطلي في اختباراتي في
مشاهدة مقاطع الفيديو  حول بورت لاكروا
وأنتاركتيكا عندما تلقيت عرضًا
للوظيفة ، كان رد فعلي الأول وكأنه مستحيل ، نعم ،
أن أحصل على وظيفة مباشرة
من الجامعة ، إنه مجرد حلم أصبح
حقيقة ، لقد
عرفت عن الحظ المتوفر روي لفترة طويلة
وأنا  لدي مخاوف جدية من أن
الأنهار الجليدية في هذا المشهد لن تبقى
هناك لفترة أطول ، لذلك شعرت أنه
من الضروري الخروج إلى هناك
وتجربتها بنفسي في أقرب وقت
ممكن في وقت معين من
الموسم ، أهداف الثلج وليس كذلك  الطين
لا يوجد طين في أنتاركتيكا ، كل شيء
ذرق الطائر أعتقد أن القارة القطبية الجنوبية هي واحدة من تلك
الأماكن التي قلة قليلة من الناس
يذهبون إليها بالفعل ، لذلك تتاح لهم
الفرصة للذهاب
لفترة طويلة من الوقت والعمل ،
فلماذا لا  تذهب لهذه
الفرصة بعد قول وداعهم ،
تبدأ الرحلة إلى القارة القطبية الجنوبية عادةً في أن
تستغرق أيامًا وتتضمن العديد من
الرحلات الجوية ورحلة بالقارب ،
لذلك وصلنا إلى Port Lottery
وهناك طيور البطريق في كل مكان
انتهيت للتو من
حفر نافذة
أنا مستوي بشكل أساسي  مع مثل الجزء العلوي من
السطح ،
فانيسا بمجرد أن يستقروا ويلتقوا
بجيرانهم الجدد ، يبدأ العمل الحقيقي
على مدى خمسة أشهر ، سيرحب الفريق
بآلاف السياح ليس فقط
للتأكد من وصول بطاقاتهم البريدية بأمان ولكن
يشرح التاريخ البحري والعلمي
لهذا  قاعدة على مر السنين ،
سيقومون أيضًا بمراقبة مستعمرة البطريق
للقيام بأعمال صيانة مهمة على
الأكواخ وقضاء الكثير من الوقت معًا في
بعض الطرق ، هذا هو بونكرز الذي يعتني
بالتراث في هذه البيئة الصعبة بشكل لا يصدق
ولكنه مهم للغاية ونحن
نمثل أو  تحكي قصة عن
فترة من تاريخ أنتاركتيكا لم
تُروى إلا قليلاً
وتيسكو لا مثيل لها في أي مكان آخر على وجه الأرض ،
إنه أمر غير عادي بحجمها البكر لدرجة أن
الهواء صافٍ للغاية وفجأة
تشعر أنك صغير جدًا